myth or truth you can't make money by
selling your short film
some people do make money so I don't
want to say and also it's not selling
it's licensing I always keep on having
to remind everybody that you're making
money by licensing your short film some
people do and and it's rare but when you
hear about it and people make a ton of
money off it we're like more power to
you good job so yeah it's rare but it is
possible myth or truth you can make a
short film with no money
I say it's true you can totally make a
short film with no money now when we say
no money do we really mean no money or
do we mean like no money but actually a
couple hundred dollars but if you
literally say I'm not going to spend any
money whatsoever then I think it's the
iPhone filmmaking that you're using your
iPhone you're doing everything yourself
you're not using professional actors
that you're paying you're doing it with
your friends and then the
post-production you either have really
good friends will help you out or there
isn't much post-production on them and
hopefully you're giving them a good
lunch or something afterwards so there
is money involved right well that's the
thing it's like well even if you say I'm
not paying anyone but I'm buying their
lunch then you know five people's lunch
even if you're you know being extremely
cheap and doing it for ten dollars which
in inflation today you can't do but
let's say even 20. there's 100 bucks
right there
for one meal for five people including
actors and director myth or truth
Executives and producers do not watch
short films
what no that's
a myth they do watch our films they
might not watch the film to the entire
ending but they they do want Hollywood
the quote I'd love to that an executive
or an agent said that I put in my book
um was that Hollywood is in love with
talents new talents so they this is
where people become show their Wares as
in short films uh so no they love short
films because there's new Talent there
are new voices and you actually can see
it so you know a lot of people have
problems getting their script seen you
know we have no connections nobody's
willing to see my shirt my script they
won't it won't take on solicited
material but they will watch a short
film because the short film already
exists so you can't say that you know we
actually had another project that was
development that was similar to it it is
there it exists and people are more
willing to look at it because you know
it's not as hazy as a script that could
be changed or we have something else in
development with it so short films can
open a lot of doors for you because
people are willing to see short films
where they're not necessarily willing to
look at a script
myth or truth a short film won't help
you get a feature made
so much not true people short there are
many examples of feature films that got
made that were developed off the short
film or that the filmmaker was hired
because they made a short film so and
then it doesn't happen all the time but
every year there's examples of
filmmakers who just made a short and
then got to make a feature so no strong
films are a fabulous launching pad to
make feature films and television
Mr truth short films are a waste of time
because there's
never a waste of time
as a filmmaker you learn something every
time you do it as a viewer you have a
chance to maybe see something you've
never seen before so I love short films
I'm the biggest proponent of short films
I never think they're a waste of time
myth or truth a short film will never
get you a Hollywood job not that's
another one that's not true so many
examples of people who have gotten use
the short film to get the job just
recently there was example of Bel Air
that he had made a it was kind of like a
trailer short film or whatever and then
they got to make a television series off
of it
um their feature films all the time that
were developed off of a short film so
myth or truth every short film gets a
million views
[Laughter]
and those tend to get more than a
million obviously if you're in that
category it becomes something that a lot
of people want to see and you'd be
surprised how many you can have seen but
um sadly so many people put their films
up and they're you know just everyone
you know watches it and that's it
why is the myth of a million viewers
unlikely
it's no longer the era if you put it up
they will come that someone's just going
to stumble upon your film and see it
that way there has to be a reason that
they've searched it out and want to see
it so um you know even with a lot of
promotion
so it's the same problem that everybody
has TV shows have it big old expensive
Hollywood features have it people only
have so much time and so when they have
so much time what are they gonna
actually watch uh I was just so some I
think it was one of your pieces where he
was complaining that people would rather
play a fortnight than watch a film so
you know it's like you're competing with
all these different uh I myself see it I
will spend all this time going on
Instagram you know and it's like that's
time I could have watched three short
films but instead I'm flipping through
people's stories on Instagram
um there's just so many other things to
take people's attention and also I mean
here I am I'm a biggest promoter of
short films but I've I know a lot of
people have seen short films that they
just thought were terrible or were dull
or were long as soon as people don't
have great experiences watching short
films it's really hard to convince them
that they want to see a short film
um so you know
very limited attention span
um where you think like it's only two
minutes can't you please watch it just
to get somebody to watch those two
minutes is very hard you know I kind of
uh or change short TV actually short TV
shows film short films on TV they have
their own channel they do license films
and try to license films Beyond it too
there are definitely ways that people
who've invested in short films and want
people to see short films and put them
out there and the Academy Award short
films that go out on the festivals on
the theatrical circuit where you can see
it in your own Hometown in the Arts
Theater so there are lots of ways that
short films do get seen in great short
films get seen I think quite often it is
that curated thing of somebody saying
when you'd like to see the short film
that won Sundance versus hey my brother
shot something on his iPhone which one
would you like to see now sometimes that
thing on the iPhone is fabulous and the
short film the one at Sundance is
painful but you know in general there is
that curation thing of I think a lot of
people would rather see the Academy
Award nominee short the Sundance award
winning short or some viral thing that
people said this is amazing you totally
have to watch it and then you watch it
Mr truth 99 of short films are awful
so
um I don't think so I think there's a
lot of great short films but you know
Sundance releases the numbers of films
that are submitted to the festival each
year and so last year in a pandemic year
over 10 000 shorts were programmed how
many did they show and of course it's
limited by how many they can actually
show but they show like 59 short films
so you know if all ten thousand of those
were amazing wouldn't that be just like
oh my God how can we not show all ten
thousand of them but no obviously what's
that number that's close to 99 of them
only
um you know 59 of them are going to be
and again I'm sure there were a lot like
150 of those other ones that should have
been programmed but they just couldn't
have been but I'm sure of those ten
thousand five thousand of them were just
you know Direct
myth or truth these days fan films are
better than Hollywood movies
well you know the Hollywood movies a lot
of people like to go see Hollywood
movies so we're not going to Discount
that whatsoever and when we say fan
films we're saying that films that are
kind of like take some existing property
um and use that in some way to make
something of their own
um and there is a passion you know why
people would be interested in is because
they're interested in that topic
um so like for example there used to be
a lot of Star Wars fan films that people
would make but um now people's tastes
are so all over the place it's hard to
know what a fan film people might be
interested in but actually I'll go back
to the Bel Air example again that that
was a fan film that he liked the
original Fresh Prince and he thought of
a unique way of doing it and made his
own version of The Fresh Prince
um that was a different take of it and
made a little short film and then people
were interested in that and as a result
of that they made it into a TV series if
it had not been with that hook a hook of
this is my reimagination of the French
Prince of Bel-Air people wouldn't have
been as an interested in it would you
say that he did a variation or a
different spin on it what was it he took
it made it dark as if you know you know
because the original concept of Fresh
Prince of Bel Air was he got in trouble
back in Philadelphia and had to come out
to Bel Air so this he made him really
get into trouble and it returned it in
very gritty and uh made it not a
happy-go-lucky sitcom but a dark you
know current day take on the idea of
somebody who got in trouble and had to
come out to California